o sol e 20 e hoje vou ensinar como fazer
e kumi naidu os corpos do jogo mortal
kombat e como vocês podem ver tem o para
porque é uma corrente na extremidade tem
e kunar e quando é muito parecida com
aquela do naruto só o inferno para tem
que esta é mais larga
quando naruto ok também dá pra ver que
esta corrente é muito forte mesmo e sei
como vai puxando muito cada lado e foi
muito difícil por dia caiu
a primeira coisa que você tem que fazer
é dobrar uma folha o banho e marca em
linha para depois cortar em e ficar e se
enquadrado prefeito precisar de uma cola
button e preencham um dos triângulos
o grupo num justo também foi de
ajustarem ao ver a mãe
dobre para linha do centro com muito
cuidado em praticar a mesma língua é por
isso que eu tracei isso mesmo por outro
lado por ficar assimétrica dobra e vejam
que foi um triângulo com as linhas
vincadas e também por colo nesta partida
para fazer o que o ney precisar duas
coisas destas
aí a atenção aqui as partes vejam que
numa partem três triângulos ou seja dois
caninos e um grande
em outra parte não tem nenhum triângulo
então o que vocês vão fazer vão deixar
espaços em triângulos para fora cá e as
partes não tem nada para dentro e
prendam com fita nestas parte embaixo
se vocês quiserem podem usar cola podem
usar outras escolas diz que não seja
button button não aguenta que eu vou
desenhar aqui uma parte para retirar
depois de depositar agora não façam esta
coisa muito grande que é isso é muito
grande pois pode não fechar
quando encaixar o cabo vou escutar essa
parte é só aprender com fita subir lá em
cima
tem que cortar e docinhos aqui é pra
fazer um espaçamento para depois
conseguir encaixar o carro cai agora
fazer o cabo a primeira coisa tem que ir
lá uma folha moda fazer uma rifa
afinal prendam com fita para não ser lá
caso vocês não consigam fazer e vou
deixar o link inscrição ensina a fazer
isso mais pegada mostrada a inflar uma
folha para fazer um tubo mas como eu
quis fazer um pouco mais grosso eu
tentei mais uma folha mas isso é com
vocês
o procedimento é o mesmo e nem com fita
por não ser lá e para ficar perfeito
time uma vez que a última folha pega um
pedaço grande empunhando um lado a outro
vejo que ela fica já com o lucro no
perto eo por cola na extremidade do
carro encaixar do modo assimétrico lá
dentro
para finalizar esta parte é só por fita
naquela partida ele e depois do outro
lado
o estado de um quadrado com 15 porque em
centros são paulo de fazer uma rifa
mas não deixei ela é muito apertada vejo
que estou soltando aos poucos
depois quando tiver mais ou menos bom
prendam expliquei pra vocês conseguirem
espalmá la facilmente terem a
extremidade que são frágeis e depois pra
eu voltar para o tamanho que o cabo de
cuidar dos corpos é muito grande e vou
usar aquela rifa para regular naquela
transição entre a parte do cabo e eco na
lâmina da culinária do estado de mais
uma folha de papel dobre a mãe recorda
ainda ninguém cada
é preciso fazer uma rifa esta aqui tem
que ficar bem apertada
vou marcar o centro desta maneira e
vejam que eu vou mudar a volta do novo
lugar fazer aquela parte final do cabo
dos coronéis
e agora só falta mesmo fazer o
correntista só enrolar outra parte
ele tem que deixar solto para conseguir
espalmar
paulo depois é só dar a forma assim
aquelas argolas da corrente e
investimento é sempre o mesmo
é só fazer argola encaixar no outro vai
fazer outra encaixar na outra é ter o
comprimento que você deseja incrível que
tem muito forte mesmo solo eu cheguei
com muita força com o meu pai me um
pouco para ter isso incrível estrutura
que vocês dão à folha ele confere uma
grande força de resistência força e
resistência
é isso pois é só encaixar essa parte com
cola e já está
chegamos ao fim então é isso aí pessoal
empregado seu estilo se vocês quiserem
ajudar o canal se deixar um like se
inscrevam caso não seja um é esse debate
ao i